hi everyone hope you're all keeping well
recently I was in Malaysia and whilst I
was there I wanted to also do some
training and decided to visit a Hema
Club after the class we decided to have
a friendly bout and I thought it'd be
interesting to share the video
the club's called SWAT krink and the
instructor Farhan was really welcoming
I'd like to thank him again for allowing
me to film whilst I was there and I'll
also leave links to his Club down below
the bout was only two minutes but I got
gassed out pretty quick bear in mind the
temperature there was about 36 degrees
with all the gear on it felt like I did
a sauna
still it was a good experience and I
wanted to share it with you all anyway I
hope you all enjoyed the video and as
always feel free to comment down below
[Music]
foreign